This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships.
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之二。这是当电梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中展现出的坚韧精神、体能以及抗压能力的种种迹象。让自己经历一些艰难困苦。
And you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J.
你将会破茧而出，成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字TWO点，可在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back At It》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家们一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯主持的《知难而进》。这个空间探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一副铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听并了解《知难而进》。2023年，“钻石单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下了一对双胞胎。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Alesspian. Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安。迈克尔·兰吉尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transatless. transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another
这是《受困的爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困的爱》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时的一些重大生活变化和惊心动魄的转折，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能回来收听另一期
episode as we of course break down the psychology of your 20s. Anxiety feels like such a curse. I'm just going to come out and say it. I think a lot of us have probably wished for a day where we weren't anxious just one day. What might that be like? Or we've considered, you know, what our lives would look like if we weren't held back by these hypothetical fears about what may or may not happen, what others might think, what disasters await, what terrible things could go wrong in our future. It is a huge burden at times. Even if it comes and goes in waves. Me and my anxiety, my pal, we go way back.
节目，当然，我们将在节目中剖析你二十岁的心理。焦虑感觉就像是一个诅咒。我只想直言不讳地说出来。我想我们很多人大概都曾祈祷过能有一天不感到焦虑，哪怕就一天。那会是怎样一种体验呢？或者我们曾思考过，你知道，如果我们不被这些关于可能会或可能不会发生的事情、别人会怎么想、会有什么灾难等待着我们、未来可能会出什么大问题的假设性恐惧所拖累，我们的生活会是什么样子。有时候，这是一个巨大的负担。即使它一阵一阵地来来去去。我和我的焦虑，我的老朋友，我们认识很久了。
I remember distinctly, so clearly, having my first ever panic attack about the movie, The Never Ending Story, when I was eight years old at like a school movie night. And since then, I've always had these moments of just extreme panic and anxiety that can go on for months or would just be this baseline of just nervousness for kind of as long as I can remember. I think I said in a recent episode that there have even, you know, been times in my life when I've worried about the fact that I'm not anxious about anything, which is absolutely bizarre. I really begun to, you know, realize that my anxiety was almost comforting in a strange way. It provided me with an illusion of security that felt quite nice when actually, although it was
我清晰地记得，非常清楚地记得，我第一次恐慌发作是在我八岁时学校的电影之夜看电影《大荒芜故事》的时候。从那以后，我总是会经历这些极度恐慌和焦虑的时刻，这些时刻可以持续好几个月，或者就像我记忆中那样，只是一种基准线的紧张感。我想我在最近的一期节目中说过，你知道，我的生活中甚至有过这样的时刻：我担心自己竟然对什么都不感到焦虑，这绝对是匪夷所思的。我真的开始意识到，你知道，我的焦虑在某种奇怪的方面几乎令人感到安慰。它给我提供了一种安全感的错觉，感觉相当不错，而实际上，虽然它
making me feel nice was making me feel like I could anticipate every single problem that would happen in my life. A, that wasn't the case. Things happened that I never could have thought of. And B, it was actually taking away from a lot of my experiences and a lot of the joyful experiences that made up for the anxious ones. You know, I would just sit with my anxious thoughts and try and problem solve them, which I think is something that we've all done. I would try and think. And think, my way through a scenario that, you know, is completely irrational. And that is just never going to work. Because even when on the rare occasion I would get through it, my brain would just present me
让我感觉不错的事情是让我觉得我可以预料到我生活中发生的每一个问题。A，事实并非如此。有些事情发生了，是我做梦也想不到的。B，它实际上剥夺了我很多经历，剥夺了许多原本可以弥补焦虑情绪的快乐经历。你知道，我会只是带着焦虑的想法坐着，试着去解决它们，我想这是我们所有人都做过的事情。我会试着思考。用思考的方式去应对一个你知道完全不理智的情景。而那是绝对行不通的。因为即使在极少数情况下我挺过去了，我的大脑也只会给我呈现
with a bigger and even trickier hypothetical. So it felt quite never-ending. And then a few years back, I started doing things differently. I stopped letting my anxiety kind of be the loudest voice in the room. I stopped letting it, you know, always be in control. And I kind of started finding ways to almost play with my anxious thoughts to like beat them at their own game, combining what I knew scientifically and psychologically about anxiety and how it operates, but also by kind of playing these mind games, these mind tricks and establishing like some pretty really, really useful tricks and tips and strategies through trial and error.
一个更大、更棘手的假设。所以感觉好像没完没了了。然后几年前，我开始做出改变。我不再让我的焦虑成为房间里声音最大的那个。我不再让它，你知道，总是掌控一切。我开始寻找各种方法，几乎像是和我的焦虑情绪玩游戏，以其人之道还治其人之身，将我在科学和心理学上对焦虑及其运作方式的了解结合起来，同时通过玩这些心理游戏、心理把戏，并通过反复试验建立一些非常、非常有用的诀窍、技巧和策略，
and what actually made me feel better did require a little bit of work, but it really helped me change my thinking from anxiety as a burden to anxiety is something that is a part of me that I can make work for me, that I can leverage in some small way. And that's exactly what I want to talk about today. Four of the ways that I've really been able to make anxiety work for me, even in really, really tough times, terrible times, really panicky, anxious times. These strategies have been like my greatest tools. And recently, I've really had to put them to the test again. And slowly but surely, they have helped me out of a tough situation.
而真正让我感觉好一点的方法确实需要付出一点努力，但它确实帮助我将对焦虑的看法从一种负担转变为焦虑是我的一部分，我可以让它为我所用，我可以以某种微小的方式利用它。这正是我今天要谈论的。我能够真正让焦虑为我所用的四种方法，即使在非常、非常艰难的时期，糟糕的时期，非常恐慌、焦虑的时期。这些策略一直是我最伟大的工具。最近，我真的不得不再次对它们进行考验。它们慢慢地、稳步地帮助我走出了困境。
So I wanted to share it with you. I hope that you can learn something. All of these tips are really practical and accessible. You could literally try them all today if you wanted. So I really hope it at least changes. how you think about your anxious thoughts, even if it doesn't change your life. Without further ado, let's get into the four ways that we can make anxiety work for us. Having a refresher on what anxiety actually is might sound really simple to begin with,
所以我很想与你们分享。希望你们能学到一些东西。所有这些小贴士都非常实用且易于上手。如果你愿意，你今天就可以把它们全部尝试一遍。所以我真的希望它至少能改变你对焦虑想法的看法，即使它没有改变你的生活。废话不多说，让我们进入让焦虑为我们所用的四种方法。复习一下焦虑到底是什么，听起来可能非常简单，
but sometimes when we're really wrapped up in our fear and our panic and our worry, we think that our anxiety means more than it does. And we really need to be, firstly, grounded in the first, fact, grounded in the facts of what we're going through. You may think you know all the information about anxiety. There is a lot to know and you probably do know quite a bit. But when you're operating from a place of survival and pure fear, your ability to actually remember this valuable information becomes quite clouded. You know, you're just not thinking straight. And we think in those moments that our anxiety is much more valid than it is, that we should believe every single thought that
但有时当我们深深陷入恐惧、恐慌和担忧中时，我们会觉得焦虑的意义比它实际的要重大。我们需要首先基于现实，基于我们正在经历的事实的真相。你可能觉得自己对焦虑无所不知。有很多知识需要了解，你可能也确实知道不少。但是当你处于生存模式和纯粹的恐惧中时，你实际记住这些宝贵信息的能力就会变得相当模糊。你知道的，你只是无法正常思考。在那些时刻，我们会觉得我们的焦虑比实际情况更有说服力，我们应该相信每一个
passes through our brains, that every opinion made up situation could be true. Because we've been hardwired to prioritize thoughts that relate to our survival, that relate to fear, that have an emotional tone to them, even if they're actually not that useful. We, I think, essentially, trust that our mind and our body, and to a certain extent, must be doing what it thinks is best. It must know what's best. It must be making us pay attention. to these hypotheticals because we are in real danger. But what we need to realize is that our trust is misplaced because anxiety's job, and this might shock you, maybe it won't, but anxiety's job is to be irrational.
掠过我们大脑的想法，认为每一个由意见构成的虚构情境都可能是真的。因为我们的大脑已经习惯于优先考虑那些与生存有关的、与恐惧有关的、带有情感基调的想法，即使它们实际上并没有那么有用。我想，本质上我们相信，我们的大脑和身体在某种程度上一定在做它认为最好的事情。它一定知道什么才是最好的。它一定是在迫使我们关注这些假设，因为我们正处于真正的危险之中。但我们需要意识到的是，我们的信任放错了地方，因为焦虑的工作——这可能会震惊到你，也可能不会——但焦虑的工作就是不理性。
That is literally its job. It is to present us with the worst case scenarios to catastrophize, to stress, to project, not to be truthful. That is not part of its job description. It's not to see a situation realistically. And why exactly is that the case? Well, because anxiety is your body and your brain trying to protect you against a perceived threat or a stressful situation, often by exaggerating an outcome or exaggerating the reality of the situation to, you know, either A help motivate you or be, try and get you to problem solve before the situation occurs. You know, I often think about anxiety like your mind trying to give you a practice exam,
这简直就是它的工作。那就是向我们展示最坏的情况，将事情灾难化、制造压力、投射，而不是说实话。那不是它职责描述的一部分。它不是为了现实地看待情况。为什么会这样呢？嗯，因为焦虑是你的身体和大脑试图保护你免受感知到的威胁或压力情况的侵害，通常是通过夸大结果或夸大情况的现实来，你知道，要么A帮助激励你，要么B，试图让你在情况发生之前就解决问题。你知道，我经常把焦虑比作你的大脑试图给你进行一次模拟考试，
but all the questions and scenarios are questions and scenarios that you'd never actually encounter in the real world or in the real exam. And they're often impossible to answer. They'll never show up in real life. And all the while, you're convincing yourself or your anxiety is convincing you, you know, this isn't a practice exam, this is the real deal. You have to take this seriously. This could actually be happening right now.
但所有的提问和场景都是你在现实世界或真正的考试中永远不会遇到的问题和场景。而且它们通常是无法回答的。它们永远不会在现实生活中出现。而在整个过程中，你一直在说服自己，或者你的焦虑在说服你，你知道，这不是模拟考试，这是来真的。你必须认真对待。这可能真的正在发生。
Now, you know, take feeling anxious about the future. What you're really experiencing is a fear of uncertainty because there is a lot you don't know. You might not know how your career is going to turn out. You might not know whether that big risk will pay off, whether you're going to meet your people, whether you're going to find love. So there is a lot of empty space. There are a lot of unknowns. Our anxiety likes to fill that space with the worst case scenario to basically say,
现在，你知道，对未来感到焦虑。你真正经历的是对不确定性的恐惧，因为有很多事情你并不wù。你可能不知道你的职业生涯会如何发展。你可能不知道那个巨大的风险是否会有回报，你是否会遇到属于你的人，是否会找到真爱。所以有很大的空白期。有很多未知数。我们的焦虑喜欢用最坏的情况来填补这个空白，基本上是在说：
okay well if you can handle this if you have a plan then we'll be fine if it comes true here's the thing though those scenarios rarely if not ever come true the scenario in which you lose everything and a fire and you make a huge mistake at work and you never get a job again and all your loved ones die that isn't going to come true the fear of you know suddenly being diagnosed with the rare disease when you were otherwise healthy, that isn't going to come true. Or, you know, your thought that everyone secretly dislikes you. You've somehow said something to upset all your close friends without anyone mentioning it. That is false.
好吧，如果你能处理好这个，如果你有一个计划，那如果它成真了，我们就没事了。但问题是，这些情况很少（如果不是从不的话）成真。那种你在火灾中失去一切、在工作犯了大错误、再也找不到工作、所有挚爱的人都死去的场景，是不会成真的。那种当你原本很健康时突然被诊断出患有罕见疾病的恐惧，是不会成真的。或者，你知道，那种每个人都暗中讨厌你的想法。你不知怎么说了什么话惹恼了所有的好朋友，而没有一个人提出来。那是假的。
It's not going to come true. It is your brain serving you up scenarios to give you a really vigorous, mental and physical workout. So if they were to happen, you would be okay because you've already experienced the anxiety towards this situation beforehand. Hopefully that makes a lot of sense to you. I think when we begin to acknowledge that this is our brain trying to protect us, but just not doing a very great job or being very helpful at all,
它不会成真。这是你的大脑在向你抛出各种场景，为你进行一场非常剧烈的心智和身体锻炼。所以如果它们真的发生了，你也会没事的，因为你之前已经经历过针对这种情况的焦虑了。希望这能让你有很大感触。我认为当我们开始承认这是我们的大脑在试图保护我们，但只是做得不是很好或一点用都没有时，
we see our situation a bit more clearly. And it has always, always helped me to remind myself that my opinion about a situation is just an opinion. Nothing more, nothing less. There's often very little evidence for what I'm, thinking and as much as I try, you know, I can't tell the future. I'm not, I don't have that rare magical ability. I cannot anticipate how this will work out. So I just have to be accepting of what comes. Of course, you know, that's very easy to think, but when your anxiety is accompanied
我们会更清楚地认清自己的处境。而且，提醒自己我对一种情况的意见仅仅是一种意见，不多不少，这一点总是、总是能帮到我。对于我正在思考的事情，往往很少有证据，而且无论我怎么努力，你知道，我都无法预测未来。我不是，我没有那种罕见的魔法能力。我无法预料事情会如何发展。所以我只能接受将要发生的事情。当然，你知道，这想起来很容易，但当你的焦虑伴随着
by a number of physical symptoms like shaking, like a rapid heartbeat, shortness of breath, trembling, nausea, sweating, or that feeling of disassociation or being unreal, it can become even more unpleasant. And I will say it makes it feel a lot more immediate. As much as those thoughts may not be true, what you're going through certainly is. The physical feeling you're going through is very real. Whether that is displayed through panic attacks,
一系列身体症状，比如发抖、心跳加快、呼吸急促、颤抖、恶心、出汗，或者那种解离或不真实感时，它就会变得更加令人不快。而且我得说，这会让它感觉更加迫在眉睫。尽管那些想法可能不是真的，但你正在经历的绝对是真的。你正在经历的身体感受是非常真实的。无论是通过恐慌发作表现出来，
through like consistent underlying anxiety, or just intrusive, repetitive thoughts, it is definitely not a comfortable experience. I don't think anyone is like, oh yeah, I love feeling anxious. That's one of my favorites. And I'm not going to be like some guru who's going to sell you snake oil and say that I can make that go away immediately or that I can cure you. But what I do want to talk about is four ways that we can take that feeling and not just
还是通过持续的潜在焦虑，或者是侵入性的、重复性的想法，这绝对不是一种舒适的体验。我想没有人会说：“哦，对，我喜欢感到焦虑。那是我的最爱之一。”我不会像某些卖蛇油的江湖郎中那样，向你兜售说我可以让它立刻消失，或者我可以治愈你。但我想谈的是四种方法，我们可以利用这种感觉，不只是
completely eliminate it, but make it work for us. And make do leverage the anxious hand, the anxious mind that you've been dealt. you know, like I said before, it's been at least 16 years that I've kind of been in the business of anxiety, but only in the last like two to three that I've really started approaching this tension, these feelings, these thoughts in a way that initially felt so counterintuitive, but actually which really, really worked. And that's the thing that I've learned with anxiety that I've found. You kind of have to beat it at its own game and just be as a irrational and delusional in your belief that you'll be fine as your anxiety is irrational and
完全消除它，而是让它为我们所用。并充分利用你所拿到的焦虑的一手牌，焦虑的大脑。你知道，就像我之前说的，我涉足焦虑这一行至少有16年了，但直到最近两三年，我才真正开始以一种最初感觉极其反直觉，但实际上却非常、非常有效的方式来对待这种紧张感、这些感受、这些想法。这就是我在焦虑中学到的、我所发现的东西。你必须以其人之道还治其人之身，在坚信自己会没事的信念上，要像你的焦虑坚信世界正在崩塌时那样不讲理、充满妄想。你需要像你的焦虑一样坚持不懈，同样充满想象力。但问题是，你其实已经知道自己可以做到所有这些，因为你的焦虑正表明你具备这种能力。所以你可以利用，
delusional in its belief that the world is falling apart. You need to be just as persistent as your anxiety is and just as imaginative. But the thing is, is that you already know that you can be all those things because your anxiety is displaying that you have that capability. So you can use, you know, the methods that your anxiety is using to scare you to kind of scare it back. This really brings me to the first way that I've stopped fighting my anxiety and really made it work for me. And that is really tricking myself into believing that anytime I feel anxiety, it's actually just excitement. And choosing to label the sensations differently to how my mind wants to label them. If my anxious mind wants to make things up, wants to label things differently as a threat when they're not,
你知道，你的焦虑用来吓唬你的那些方法来反过来吓唬它。这真正引出了我停止与焦虑抗争并真正让它为我所用的第一种方法。那就是欺骗自己，相信每当我感到焦虑时，其实这只是兴奋。并选择给这些感觉贴上与我大脑想要贴的标签不同的标签。如果我的焦虑大脑想要凭空捏造，想要在不是威胁的时候把它们贴上威胁的标签，
If my anxious mind wants to lie to me, well, I can lie right back. You know, it sounds like I'm fighting this like, you know, mortal enemy, but here's the thing, right? Like, there's a perk, not so much a perk, but something unusual about feeling anxious that works in our favour, anxiety and excitement are actually incredibly similar on so many dimensions. And they tend to actually activate the same kind of arousal pathways in our body. There's a really amazing article from the Harvard Business School titled Get Excited, Reapraising Anxiety as Excitment. And it talks about how both anxiety and excitement are based on knowing, or not knowing what to expect. They're based on high levels of arousal, so basically meaning a similar level of bodily response to a stimulus.
如果我的焦虑大脑想要对我说谎，好吧，我也可以反过来对它说谎。听起来好像我是在跟这个，你知道，死敌搏斗，但事情是这样的，对吧？关于感到焦虑，有一个好处，与其说是好处，不如说是某种不寻常的地方，它对我们有利，焦虑和兴奋在很多维度上其实惊人地相似。而且它们往往会在我们的身体中激活同一种唤醒通路。哈佛商学院有一篇非常精彩的文章，题为《兴奋起来：将焦虑重新评价为兴奋》。文章谈到焦虑和兴奋都是基于了解或不知道会发生什么。它们都基于高度的唤醒，基本上意味着身体对刺激的反应水平相似。
And they're based on a sense or a loss of control. when you're excited, you're going to feel perhaps equally jittery, kind of nervous, you're going to feel your heart rate go up, maybe all these thoughts start swirling around about what is possible. That's very similar to an anxious state. The only difference is what we would call positive or negative valence. So valence or valency is this idea in psychology that describes how different emotions have a different emotional effect. even if they feel the same on a physical level. So anxiety and excitement, they feel the same on a physical level,
而且它们基于一种掌控感或失控感。当你感到兴奋时，你可能会感到同样的心神不宁、有点紧张，你会感觉到心率上升，也许所有这些关于可能发生的事情的想法开始在脑海中盘旋。这与焦虑的状态非常相似。唯一的区别是我们所谓的积极或消极效价。所以效价或价态是心理学中的一个概念，用来描述不同的情绪具有不同的情感效果，
but anxiety has a negative valence, whereas excitement has a positive valence, meaning that the emotional effect of excitement is appealing, it's desirable, it makes us more attracted to a situation, whereas anxiety has that negative valence, it makes us scared, fearful, uncomfortable. So I want you to tap into that positive, emotional, valency. If the only thing that is different is how we interpret a feeling, then tell yourself,
即使它们在身体层面上的感觉是一样的。所以焦虑和兴奋，它们在身体层面上感觉是一样的，但焦虑具有消极效价，而兴奋具有积极效价，这意味着兴奋的情感效果是吸引人的、令人向往的，它让我们对情况更感兴趣，而焦虑具有那种消极效价，它让我们感到害怕、恐惧、不舒服。所以我希望你们能挖掘那种积极的、情绪化的价态。如果唯一的区别在于我们如何诠释一种感觉，那么告诉自己，
actually, I'm excited by this feeling. This is an anxiety. This is excitement about how this is going to turn out. I'm excited to see how I manage this. I'm excited to be able to have this human experience. And, you know, I used this technique a lot when I was getting over my fear of flying. I would get incredibly panicked, especially during taking. off and so I would just keep repeating that, you know, this is actually an excited feeling. I'm excited by this feeling. This is not anxiety. These are butterflies. This is not adrenaline. It's enthusiasm. And that same research paper from Harvard that I referenced before actually concluded that using this technique can improve our performance like a lot in certain situations,
实际上，我对这种感觉感到兴奋。这不是焦虑。这是对事情会如何发展的兴奋。我很高兴看到自己如何应对这种情况。我很高兴能有这种人类体验。而且，你知道，当我克服恐慌症时，我经常使用这个技巧。我曾惊恐万分，尤其是在飞机起飞的时候，所以我就会不断重复，你知道，这实际上是一种兴奋的感觉。我对这种感觉感到兴奋。这不是焦虑。这是紧张的蝴蝶效应。这不是肾上腺素。这是热情。我之前引用的哈佛那篇研究论文实际上得出结论：使用这种技巧可以在很大程度上提高我们在某些情况下的表现，
especially when it comes to things to do with social anxiety, public speaking, specific phobia situations and it's a much better strategy if you know than trying to just completely shut down our anxiety completely because going from anxious to calm is a lot harder there are a lot more nuances and differences compared from compared to going from anxious to excited because they are on the same kind of end of the spectrum that is tip number one but we're going to take a short break I hope that you stay with us, and I hope that you are excited for the next three strategies I have for you when we're back. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%.
特别是在涉及社交焦虑、公开演讲、特定恐惧症情况的事情方面，如果你知道的话，这比试图完全彻底关闭我们的焦虑要好得多，因为从焦虑到平静要困难得多，相比于从焦虑到兴奋，里面有更多的细微差别和不同，因为它们在光谱的同一种类上，这是第一招，但我们要稍作休息，希望你能留下来，希望你对我们回来后的接下来三个策略感到兴奋。2%。这就是当电梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past. the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app.
我将剖析我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中展现出的坚韧精神、体能以及抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上对之感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会破茧而出，成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即T-W-O-P-e-r-s-e-n-t，可在iHeart Radio应用、
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA上拍了两次小金姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back At It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。
Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的快克。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备聊聊84年的快克，不过让你们知道一下。我的意思是，在这一点上，这是我们讨论快克的第二期节目。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿线。
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist,
我们现在也把艾滋病摆在了桌面上。谢谢你补充完这句话。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《知难而进》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师，
Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough.
科尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我将把我在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐本身，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却仍然在追逐，而且不知道什么时候才算做够了。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的竞赛。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
我希望你真正地做一个好人。加入我，科尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《知难而进》中，进行关于疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct?
2023年，前钻石单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己陷入了亲子关系丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这拉开了长达数年的法律之战以证明真相。欧文斯女士，你伪造了某个特定测试两次，对吧？
I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detainees. to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Maranini.
我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉尼尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura O'clock. Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困的爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被以欺诈罪起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，事情还没结束。
Listen to a love trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. The easiest way to tell of something is an anxious thought is when it starts with what if. What if the world collapses? What if my worst fear comes true? What if I never achieve what I want? What if I lose it all? A true fear, something that is actually dangerous in the moment, wouldn't require that what if prefix because you would know it was happening.
在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困的爱》播客。判断一件事是否是焦虑想法的最简单方法，就是当它以“万一”开头时。万一世界崩塌了怎么办？万一我最害怕的恐惧成真了怎么办？万一我永远无法实现我想要的目标怎么办？万一我失去一切怎么办？真正的恐惧，即当下真正危险的事情，不需要“万一”这个前缀，因为你会知道它正在发生。
It would be happening right now in the moment. And this is really valuable to pay attention to because the moment you find yourself spiraling, overthinking, getting repetitive with your thoughts, and they all start with what if, that is anxiety, that is not reality, it's a thought, not a fact. here's how you can make this work for you. Again, what you're really fearing here is the unknown. And it's not uncommon for us to have, you know, five, six, seven different hypotheticals about what could happen or going at once or swirling around or feeling equally scary and unlikely. What we forget to realize is that they can't all possibly come true. But yet we feel bombarded with an almost cumulative worry, right?
它会就在当下的这一刻发生。注意到这一点非常有价值，因为当你发现自己陷入螺旋式下降、过度思考、想法重复，并且它们都以“万一”开头时，那就是焦虑，而不是现实。这是一个想法，而不是事实。以下是如何让这一点为你所用。再次强调，你在这里真正害怕的是未知。我们对可能发生的事情有五、六、七种不同的假设，它们同时出现或在脑海中盘旋，感觉同样可怕且不太可能，这并不罕见。我们忘记意识到的是，它们不可能同时成真。然而，我们却感到受到几乎是累积起来的担忧的轰炸，
that each of these hypotheticals could be a possibility. And that's one of the first ways that we see that anxiety is really, really irrational, because that's not possible. And I want you to fight these unknowns with knowns. Yes, you don't know how the future will pan out or what will happen in this situation, but you do know a lot of things, and you are certain of a lot of things. You know that you are capable. You know that you've survived every situation you've been in before.
即每一个假设都可能成为现实。这是我们发现焦虑非常、非常不理性的最初方式之一，因为那是不可能的。我希望你用已知来对抗这些未知。是的，你不知道未来会如何发展，也不知道在这种情况下会发生什么，但你确实知道很多事情，并且对很多事情确信不疑。你知道自己是有能力的。你知道你已经在之前遇到的每一种情况中生存下来了。
You know that this is just anxiety. What else do you know? You do know that your fears rarely ever come true. You do know that you are not alone. You do know that you, you know, many others have been through this and come out the other side. There is one uncertainty. The uncertainty is what's going to happen in this situation, what's going to happen next. But there are many, many certainties. And that is what I want you to focus on, what you do know, what you are certain of compared to what you are uncertain of, and see how like the certainties end up stacking up in your favor. Here's a really great visualization exercise that I use with this as well is I like pretend
你知道这只是焦虑。你还知道什么？你确实知道你的恐惧很少成真。你确实知道你不是一个人。你确实知道你，你知道，许多其他人也经历过这一切并挺了过来。只有一个不确定性。不确定性是这种情况下会发生什么，接下来会发生什么。但有很多、很多的确定性。这就是我希望你关注的，与你的不确定性相比，你所知道的、你所确定的事情，看看这些确定性是如何最终叠加并对你有利的。这里有一个非常棒的可视化练习，我也将其用于此，我喜欢假装
that I'm holding these certainties in my hand and they are these big golden orbs, these big, like weird golden balls and I like mentally throw them at my fears, at my anxious thoughts. And I think about the fears as like this big shadowy, you know, shadowy figure. And I'm throwing these big certainty golden orbs at them and they're just crashing through this shadow, making it smaller and smaller and smaller, making it fall apart until it's gone. And these certainties really pierced through that uncertainty, both in like the visualization, but also in your life. Like you really start to believe that yes, I, you know, you do know that this is going to pass. You do know that there are all these factual things that you can rely on.
我把这些确定性握在手里，它们是巨大的金色光球，巨大的、奇怪的金色球体，我会在精神上把它们扔向我的恐惧，扔向我焦虑的想法。我把恐惧想象成一个巨大的、阴暗的、你知道的，阴暗的身影。我把这些巨大的确定性的金色光球扔向它们，它们直接穿透了这片阴影，让它变得越来越小、越来越小、越来越小，直到它消失。这些确定性真正穿透了那种不确定性，无论是在可视化中，还是在你的生活中。就像你真的开始相信，是的，我，你知道，你确实知道这一切终将过去。你确实知道有所有这些你可以依赖的事实。
you do know at the very least that you trust yourself to get through this. That is something that you are absolutely sure of. The reason that I find this so effective is because it gives me the opportunity to remember that I am capable no matter what situation I encounter. Again, anxiety's job is to be irrational. But so often afterwards, we never get the opportunity to remember what it was we were fearing because it doesn't come true. So anxiety's job is really to torment us, not to give us.
你至少知道你信任自己能够度过难关。这是你绝对确信的事情。我发现这如此有效的原因是，它给了我一个机会去提醒自己，无论遇到什么情况，我都是有能力的。再次强调，焦虑的工作就是不理性。但很多时候在这之后，我们再也没有机会去回忆我们害怕的是什么，因为它并没有成真。所以焦虑的工作实际上是在折磨我们，而不是给我们提供
factual scenarios that we actually are going to encounter. You can instead use this situation to learn about yourself, to reinforce that you are confident, that you trust yourself rather than trusting your anxiety. And you've got to remember a lot of people don't get tested this way. A lot of people go through life, just assuming things. And you're someone who is going to instead take that discomfort, take all those situations in which you felt fear and really pay attention to the fact that you got through it. And really remember that for the future, that you are an incredibly strong person to be facing
我们真正会遇到的现实情境。你反而可以利用这种情况来了解自己，来强化你的自信，让你相信自己而不是相信你的焦虑。你必须记住，很多人没有经历过这种考验。很多人一生都在想所当然。而你将成为这样一个人，你将接受这种不适感，接受所有那些让你感到恐惧的情况，并真正注意到你度过难关的事实。并为未来牢牢记住这一点，记住你是一个非常坚强的人，敢于面对
a battle that is originating from you, that is originating from the deepest fears that you could possibly encounter being made to feel real. I just think you will experience true pride and joy that you persevered. And I want you to have that experience. I want you to have that experience. I want you to make that happen for yourself. Now, the third way that I make anxiety work for me rather than against me is by personifying my anxiety as something that isn't threatening. So my mom was actually the one who really inspired me to kind of start thinking about my anxiety this way because of something that she said to me once when I was really, really stuck. You know, she'd seen me kind of battle with some pretty existential fears for a long time. And one day she was like, the fears you have now,
源自你自身的战斗，源自你可能遇到的最深层恐惧变成现实的战斗。我只是觉得你将体验到真正的自豪和喜悦，因为你坚持了下来。我希望你能有这种体验。我希望你能拥有这种体验。我希望你能为自己实现这一点。现在，我让焦虑为我所用而不是与我作对的第三种方法，是将我的焦虑拟人化为一个没有威胁的东西。所以我妈妈实际上是启发我开始这样思考焦虑的人，因为她有一次在我陷入困境时对我说的话。你知道，她看到我和一些存在主义的恐惧搏斗了很长时间。有一天她说，你现在拥有的恐惧，
are no different to when you were a kid and you were scared of the boogeyman or you were scared of the monster in your closet. You know, it's just all smoke, right? And thinking about my anxiety is this tangible thing that wasn't scary, except for in my imagination, turned a lot of it around for me. So now I try to personify my anxiety as this is so strange, but as Boo from Monsters Inc. Now, if you've ever seen that movie, it's a classic. I'm assuming that you have, but, you know, boo is the little girl and when she's she's like wearing this little monster costume and she jumps out and she goes like boo and obviously like sully and mike wasalski like get really really scared but it's like it's just a little kid right and that's how i like to imagine my anxiety trying to scare me like a little
和你小时候害怕大灰狼或衣橱里的怪物没有什么不同。你知道，这都只是烟雾，对吧？把我的焦虑想象成这样一个有形的东西，除了在我的想象中之外并不吓人，这为我扭转了很大一部分局面。所以现在我试着把我的焦虑拟人化为《怪兽电力公司》里的阿布。现在，如果你看过那部电影，它是一部经典之作。我假设你看过，但是，你知道，阿布是一个小女孩，当她穿着这套小怪物服装跳出来说“boo”的时候，显然苏利和迈克·瓦斯基会吓得要死，但这就只是个小孩子，对吧？这就是我喜欢想象我的焦虑试图吓唬我的方式——就像一个玩耍的小孩，而我正在陪着他们玩，他们说“boo”，然后我说：“哦，我好害怕，好可怕啊。”但实际上我能看出这只是一个无害的小东西，一个小东西，
kid that's like playing and i'm like playing along with them and they're like boo and i'm like oh i'm so terrified how scary but really i can see that it's just this little harmless being this little thing that is, you know, not actually going to hurt me. Because, you know, really, your anxiety is just like a little kid playing make believe. It can't jump out and rip off your limbs. It can't pull your hair. It can't do anything to you externally. It is a feeling and one that has originated from you. So it will not harm you as uncomfortable as it feels. Giving it a name, giving it a little costume, giving it an identity maybe, it lets us remember that what we're really dealing with here is a boogeyman, or in my case, you know, a little kid playing dress up who's trying to scare you.
（你知道，它）实际上并不会伤害我。因为，说实话，你的焦虑就像一个玩假装游戏的小孩。它不能跳出来扯断你的四肢。它不能扯你的头发。它在外部对你做不了任何事。它只是一种感觉，而且源自于你。所以它不会伤害你，尽管感觉起来很不舒服。给它起个名字，给它穿上一套小服装，也许给它一个身份，能让我们记住，我们在这里真正处理的是一个妖怪，或者在我的情况下，你知道，一个玩着换装游戏试图吓唬你的小孩。
This has the additional benefit of meaning that you can kind of almost speak to your anxiety like it's a person, like it's, you know, an annoying visitor in your house or a little kid, you're asking it to leave, you're in control, and you can kind of also tease it and joke around with it and tell it to chill out. One of my friends calls her anxiety Brian, like brain, but with the eye, and the A-swab to get the picture. And she's so cute because she'll be like, oh, you know, Brian is just holding us up today, so I'm running a little bit late. Or, you know, Brian is really overthinking this. Can you tell them to chill out? Can you reassure me? Now, you know, it's like if she needs to cancel plans, she needs more information, she needs
这还有一个额外的好处，意味着你几乎可以像对一个人说话那样对你的焦虑说话，就像它是，你知道，你家里一个讨厌的访客或一个小孩子，你要求它离开，你在掌控之中，你也可以取笑它、跟它开玩笑并告诉它冷静点。我的一个朋友把她的焦虑叫作布莱恩（Brian），就像大脑（brain）那个词，但把字母换了一下，你们懂的。她太可爱了，因为她会说：“哦，你知道，布莱恩今天把我们绊住了，所以我有点迟到了。”或者，“你知道，布莱恩对这个想太多了。你能告诉他冷静点吗？你能安抚我一下吗？”现在，你知道，就好像如果她需要取消计划，她需要更多信息，她需要
reassurance. It's not her asking for it. It's Brian. maybe in a way that kind of reduces some of the stigma or the sense that you're demanding or that you're the problem because this separation of you and your anxiety into a character makes you realize that you are in fact not your anxiety you are just a person doing the best they can with what they have and the hand that they've been dealt even if that hand involves a little friend who likes to jump out and scare you my final tip today for making your anxiety work for you rather than against you for reprogramming our relationship with this state is to take the tension, take the hopelessness, take the nervousness and channel it into something
保证。这不是她在要求。是布莱恩在要求。也许在某种程度上，这减少了一些耻辱感，或者减少了那种你在无理取闹或你才是问题的感觉，因为将你和你的焦虑分离开来成为一个角色，让你意识到你其实并不是你的焦虑，你只是一个尽自己所能应对生活发给你的一手牌的人，即使这手牌包含了一个喜欢跳出来吓唬你的小淘气。我今天的最后一个小贴士，教你如何让焦虑为我所用而不是与我作对，如何重新编写我们与这种状态的关系，那就是把紧张感、绝望感、紧张情绪引导并转化成某种
creative. That energy you have has to go somewhere. And yes, it can definitely be expressed through tears or panic or muscle tension or trembling, but it can also be expressed emotionally through creation. Now, I'm not saying production. I'm not saying to take all that nervous energy and that false alarm focus and be productive and work on, you know, your school project or whatever it is or work on your assignment or doing something that's, you know, necessarily helpful. I'm saying be creative for a reason because what I think really helps us pro-sex anxiety is building something, molding something for the sake of just making something beautiful. Anxiety puts us in a state of helplessness, scarcity, stuckness, deficit.
创造力。你拥有的那种能量必须有个去处。是的，它绝对可以通过眼泪、恐慌、肌肉紧张或颤抖来表达，但它也可以通过创造来以情感的方式表达。现在，我指的不是生产。我不是说要将所有那些紧张的能量和虚假警报的焦点转化为生产力，去从事你的学校项目或任何事情，去完成你的作业，或者做一些必然有帮助的事情。我是说要出于某种原因发挥创造力，因为我认为真正有助于我们应对焦虑的是去建造某样东西，去塑造某样东西，仅仅为了创造出美好的事物。焦虑让我们陷入一种无助、匮乏、停滞和赤字的心理状态。
We feel like life is kind of meaningless at times or like everything could be taken away from us. Our safety, our lives are at risk. Creativity is the exact opposite. Painting, buying $4 clay from your craft store, knitting, building Legos, scrapbooking, diary entries, writing poetry, whatever it is. That shows abundance. That shows healing. That shows that you can be in control.
我们有时会觉得生活毫无意义，或者觉得一切都可能被夺走。我们的安全、我们的生命正处于危险之中。创造力则恰恰相反。绘画、从工艺品店买4美元的黏土、织毛衣、搭乐高、做剪贴簿、写日记、写诗，无论是什么。这展现了富足。这展现了治愈。这表明你可以掌控一切。
You can put beautiful things back into the world and channel again. Yes, that anxiety. Channel it into something meaningful rather than something meaningless. I cite this paper all the time. So for my regular listeners, I am going to sound like a broken record. but a 2021 paper on the positive effects of creativity looked at over 500 adults who were asked to just engage in a small creative task each day for less than 10 minutes and after two weeks their subjective well-being was measured and what they found was that for those who were given the
你可以把美好的事物重新带回这个世界，并再次进行引导。是的，那种焦虑。把它引导到有意义的事情上，而不是无意义的事情上。我经常引用这篇论文。所以对于我的老听众来说，我听起来可能会像个复读机，但一篇2021年关于创造力积极作用的论文研究了500多名成年人，他们被要求每天进行一项持续不到10分钟的小型创意任务，两周后，他们的主观幸福感得到了测量，他们发现，对于那些被赋予
direction to be creative they were so much happier and the biggest area where the researchers saw a shift was reduced anxiety. In my mind, anxiety is just energy. And energy doesn't disappear. It needs a place to go. It needs direction. When you begin to master your anxiety more, you can kind of channel it in the ways that you want.
发挥创造力指令的人来说，他们要快乐得多，研究人员发现发生转变最大的领域是焦虑感的减轻。在我看来，焦虑只是一种能量。而能量是不会消失的。它需要一个去处。它需要方向。当你开始更好地掌控你的焦虑时，你可以按照你想要的方式去引导它。
And creative expression is one of the easiest ways to do that initially. You take that energy that is all yours. It is yours to use. and you use it to create, to expand, to build, rather than to let your anxiety convince you that nothing changes, all your fears come true, they won't, I promise, this is just a survival instinct, this is just a stress response. Your brain is doing its best to prepare you,
而创造性的表达最初是最简单的方法之一。你拿走那完全属于你的能量。它是属于你使用的，你用它来创造、来拓展、来建设，而不是让你的焦虑说服你认为一切都不会改变，你所有的恐惧都会成真，它们不会的，我向你保证，这只是一种生存本能，这只是一种压力反应。你的大脑正在尽最大努力为你做准备，
but its best is also very imaginative and out there. You know, you've got a really creative mind. That's what, you know, I've had a friend say to me once, She was like, yeah, you're just very creative. And so take that creativity. You can either use it to make up, cook up like the most crazy hypotheticals, or you can use it to create something beautiful that's going to add to your life. So as a refresh before we wrap up, here are the four ways that you're going to try.
但它的努力也极具想象力和异想天开。你知道的，你有着非常具有创造力的思维。这就是，你知道的，我曾听一个朋友对我说过，她说，是的，你真的很有创造力。所以，运用这种创造力。你要么可以用它来编造、炮制出最疯狂的假设，要么你可以用它来创造一些能为你的生活增添光彩的美好事物。所以在我们结束之前，做个复习，这里有你要尝试的四种方法。
Maybe you can try one, you can try two. You're going to use these to make your anxiety work for you. hopefully you will go away and when you feel panic worry stress you will tell yourself that it's excitement you will have an ongoing list of the things that you do know to engulf the things that you don't know you will put a name to your anxiety you'll visualize your worries you'll make a character out of it and finally when your anxiety tells you to be small tells you to deconstruct your life instead be creative build something make something even if it's like terrible even if it's shit even if you don't think it's particularly pretty you'll enjoy the process and it will give the
也许你可以尝试一种，你可以尝试两种。你要用这些方法让你的焦虑为你所用。希望你会离去，当你在感到恐慌、担忧、压力时，你会告诉自己那是兴奋，你将拥有一份持续更新的清单，列出你所了解的事物，以此来包容你所未知的事物，你会给你的焦虑起个名字，你会把你的担忧具象化，把它变成一个角色，最后，当你的焦虑叫你变得渺小、叫你解构你的人生时，去发挥创造力吧，去建设某些东西，去创造某些东西，哪怕它很糟糕，哪怕它是垃圾，哪怕你觉得它一点也不漂亮，你也会享受这个过程，它会给这些
energy again somewhere to go when you turn that creative energy that you have away from the scary hypotheticals and into something beautiful and magnificent so i really do hope that if you're going through an anxious period i think that the biggest comfort for me has been knowing that I am not alone. And you're definitely not alone either because I can say, hand on my chest, that I am feeling it pretty intensely at the moment. So we're in the same boat.
能量再次找到一个去处。当你把你的创造性能量从可怕的假设中转移开，投入到某种美丽而宏伟的事物中时，所以我真的希望，如果你正在经历一段焦虑的时期，我认为对我来说最大的安慰是知道我并不孤单。你当然也绝不孤单，因为我可以把手放在胸前说，我此刻对此有着相当强烈的感觉。所以我们同舟共济。
I promise you. And we'll get through it. We definitely will get through it because your body cannot be in this state forever. It just can't. We know that biologically. We know that. Just when we learn about the stress response, that it's not possible.
我向你保证。我们会挺过去的。我们绝对会挺过去的，因为你的身体不可能永远处于这种状态。它就是不可能。我们从生物学上知道这一点。我们知道这一点。正如我们了解压力反应时所知的那样，这是不可能的。
So please hold on, try some of these tips. I promise it gets better. I promise this is just. your imagination working overtime, which is a beautiful thing sometimes, but sometimes less than helpful. And yeah, I hope that you find some peace in your day today. I hope that this episode has brought you some peace. If you did enjoy it, please make sure that you are following along on Spotify or Apple Podcasts. Leave a five-star review, especially if you're listening on Apple actually, because we actually don't have many listeners over there. So any reviews really do help. And of course,
所以请坚持住，尝试一下这些建议。我保证情况会变好的。我保证这只是你的想象力在超负荷运转，这有时是一件美好的事，但有时却没什么帮助。好吧，我希望你今天能获得一些平静。我希望这一集能给你带来一些平静。如果你确实喜欢它，请确保你在Spotify或Apple Podcasts上关注我们。留下一条五星好评，尤其是如果你在Apple上听的话，因为我们在那里的听众其实不多。所以任何评价都真的很有帮助。当然，
I read every single one of them so they don't go unnoticed. And if you have an episode suggestion, if you have a follow-up to this episode, a question, a query, an additional tip that you think people might also benefit from. Please share it with me at that psychology podcast. Until next time, stay safe. Be kind, be gentle to yourself, and we will talk soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我阅读每一条评论，所以它们不会被忽视。如果你有关于节目的建议，如果你对这一集有后续想法、问题、疑问，或者有你认为对其他人也有帮助的额外小建议。请在That Psychology Podcast上与我分享。下次见之前，请保持安全。善待自己，对自己温柔一些，我们很快就会聊到2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。
I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。我在这里剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和培养抗挫力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端迎来
a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. % on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a Podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me.
一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。注意是数字的2和百分号。重温播客。对于1979年来说，那对我来说是一个重要时刻。
84 is big to me. I'm Sam Jay And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
84对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·杰伊，我是亚克斯·英格利士。在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着通过我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家，来弄清楚我们是如何在其中生存下来的。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to learn the hard way
就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代一样。84年是疯狂的一年。我认为没有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回首往事》。嘿，你们好吗？你们正在收听《艰难学习》
with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast,
我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·加姆斯。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在任何地方说其实都不安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcast上收听《艰难学习》，
or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
或在任何你获取播客的地方收听。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个同性恋。
Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的天哪，太震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困于爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困于爱》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本期节目暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。